pour 2017 pour la fera quoi ce que
j'aimerais c'est vous présentiez à la
manière des manuels macro ou stratégie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'était boîte de nuit c'est ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que vous êtes le
meilleur des publics non à la censure
vous êtes des gagnants
[Applaudissements]
il imite rester belle fille vénale
attention elle dit lourdeur je suis sûr
qu'il va être lourd mais ça va être une
thalasso bonsoir à tous
le permet vous donner des chiffres
je vais vous donner mes blagues
d'ailleurs vous savez comment on y
châteaufort château voilà ça c'est drôle
merde pour 2017
on a eu chaud
[Applaudissements]
ça va pour 2017
je veux une émission sur ces 8 et 6 ans
tous ses chroniqueurs qui m'emmerde bien
on rigole plus il fait passer des
messages personnels
écoutez il a perdu beaucoup d'eau et n'a
plus toute sa tête
[Rires]
très haut tout à soir après soir
bonsoir je suis jean luc lemoine je suis
heureux d'être là ce soir je suis
heureux parce que je suis avec vous avec
vous tous sur pourquoi parce que ce soir
je vais manger des frites
vous avez les frais de public
villeneuve a mal joué nous
[Applaudissements]
l'afrique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
française 30 16 passes de ses numéros de
ma chambre
deux heures c'est le temps que
j'accorderai à chacune d'entre vous 24
c'est la taille de ma loge et oui
concède française et je vous le dis si
vous tes pour moi eh ben ils
s'arrêteraient peut-être de kate ne vous
arrêterez pas personne ne serait arrêté
vive la tuerie de la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]